For much of this class we will be working with the data set of
World Cup game statistics.
Each row of our data set represents a single World Cup game,
excluding preliminary games.
And each column represents some piece of information on the game.
Here we have the year of the World Cup in which the game was played,
the time the game happened at.
The full date including the day and the month.
The two teams that played, team 1 and team 2.
The number of people who attended the match in person at the stadium.
Which stage of the World Cup the match occurred in.
The final score of the game.
The first number representing Team 1's score.
And the second number representing Team 2's score.
And whether or not the game went to penalty kicks.
One point on this is that penalty kicks only happen if the game was
tied by the time it ended.
Which chart, type of the charts we've covered earlier in
this lesson do you think is most suited to present the total attendance for
a given year of the World Cup?
In other words, you would aggregate all the rows of the games for
the same year and sum up the attendance for every one of those games.
And also think about, why would you choose that chart?
Please choose only one of the chart types below that you think
best represents the data, and also think about why you've chosen that chart.